[Music]
welcome to here biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today not at the
round table of dim lighting but at a
table we set up in a hotel suite at
VidCon is British youtuber vlogger and
filmmaker and friend Charlie McDonnell
Charlie was one of the first vloggers
and a UK to reach 1 million subscribers
he since racked up 2.4 million subs with
290 million video views on his main
channel Charlie is so cool like that's
all one word charlie is so cool like ice
channel really took off way back in 2007
after he released a video called how to
be English in that video he was 16 years
old and that 16 year old Charlie teaches
us how to properly enjoy a cup of tea
here's a clip I'm going to be showing
you the ancient English art that is
making a cup of tea firstly you will
need to get your tea making equipment
this consists of a kettle complete with
water a bug a tea spoon milk either
steady skim milk sugar for those of you
with a sweet now Charlie's fan base
really started growing after that video
and of course so did his love of tea
beyond vlogging charlie has written and
directed several short films that you
can find on his chin on one of them is
called the tea chronicles which is a
short psychological horror slash comedy
about tea here's a clip from that you
could not make tea to save your life do
you know that I've never in all of my
days tasted anything so foul do you even
know what stirring is charlie it was the
sugar yes the sugar it was hardly
dissolved at all it was all collected in
the bottom of the muck but with the milk
to you you gave me a dollop of hoe and I
only did a drop of semi I bet you put
the milk in first too didn't you you
monster
it was mr. weak are you you giving me
decaf or something because I just kind
it's just a cup of tea charlie is an OG
youtuber who is still continuing to
innovate on the platform after all these
years and we've always appreciated his
thoughtful approach to everything he
does
including the way he approached this
conversation with us yeah I had a great
conversation we discussed lots of things
including why at the start of his
YouTube career he was scared into
deleting a lot of his videos we also
talked about working with his girlfriend
Emily who's also a filmmaker and the
quality time they recently spent on a
topless beach uh-huh
and we even got a chance to clear the
air over a joke we made when we followed
his short film on stage at buffer fest
in Toronto last year right and we talked
a little bit at the end about his new
show and YouTube channel cereal time so
stay tuned for that
but first we want to take a moment to
mention our sponsor for today's episode
Squarespace
Squarespace is the easiest way to create
a beautiful website blog or online store
for you and your ideas
Squarespace features an elegant
interface beautiful templates an
incredible 24/7 customer support
try squarespace is squarespace.com and
enter offer code rhett and Link at
checkout to get 10% off Squarespace
build it beautiful and now onto the
biscuit okay Charlie so we've we're
serving UT yeah of course
and like it's this is such a pressurized
moment are you judging that tea as
you're sipping the tea and I feel like
I'm we're failing is that also is that
hotel tea know we brought like our own
little like cake cup thing and we have
like in English breakfast tea
like literally we've just served charlie
English breakfast tea did you bring the
breakfast tea with you for you I think
really I'm certainly not drinking any of
that I liked when I came in you're like
you want to drink you want water soda
pop maybe a coffee you didn't like
coffee tea and I was I didn't offer you
tea but I cuz I think we don't want you
know what ER yeah we wanted you to make
the decision we knew what decision you
would make but it's about empowering you
to make your own decision but you didn't
want to push the tea on you you have
your own tea blend I do yeah yeah that
you sell I I make my own tea it's good
quality
my quality blend it's kinda like a
masala chai type of thing is quality
like
you know big on te oh no actually I love
the idea of tea yeah yep but I can't
make myself like it as much as coffee
currently yeah I'm pretty pretty big on
coffee yeah I have a bit of a caffeine
intolerance so like teas as much
caffeine as I can take coffee just kind
of sends me a bit mad okay but it's
quite his quality a brand name that then
you have like the Charlie blend as part
of it yeah well my production company
has cooled quality productions and then
I took that and made my own team okay
like my quality I didn't know if it was
like coke like had like a charlie soda
but really quality is your production
company oh okay
so you're literally just making this T
like what out of your basement or
something you've got like a no I I have
a tea guy um I actually did a thing with
with comic relief which is a charity in
the UK they wanted to do something cool
with me and they suggested going to me
to like a master tea blender learning
about how to blend tea and at the end of
it he could have made a tea based on my
kind of like specific tea preferences
and then we what are your specific tea
preferences well apparently I like a
spicy tea okay and I like it I kind of
wanted a tea that was quite like was a
bit of a treat generally I'll go for
what I have here today which is English
breakfast tea with a bit of milk
semi-skimmed here which i think is half
and half here semi simmered in the UK
sorry and well I should say that this
test is perfectly serviceable it's great
and I'm not you've got such a way with
words perfectly but I don't know how to
take that tell me because when it comes
to coffee for instance there's such a
spectrum of coffee right and there's a
lot of bad coffee on the coffee spectrum
most hotel coffee that you're gonna get
most coffee that it's like one of those
little coffee makers that's in your room
or like the weird circular coffee filter
that you throw in there or gas station
very bad food it's just horrible it is
not serviceable unless the only service
you're trying to give yourself is a
caffeine boost but
the same way I feel like I have a pretty
low benchmark for kind of like like in
my tea like tea bags in the UK usually
can come from like the the scrapings of
the bottom of like the factories it's
just like sort of tea dust and that's
kind of what I'm used to that's kind of
like fine for me just a guy who now
sells us Antibes I don't think you
should you should toe that line Iona be
like - Luton man yeah I'm comfortable
being honest with my tea preferences
that I'm not super picky when I say this
is serviceable that's like for me that's
good
okay I couldn't drink it and I'm
enjoying it and that's fine I'm really
am not that picky but is that master tea
blender now manufacturing your tea or
you sublet that to somebody else to the
master tea blender has his own like tea
factory factory saying where he blends
the tea and he can make it into banks
and do all of that stuff for me and what
is this guy like he's lovely he's very
very smart very knowledgeable about tea
like I made the whole video on your
channel yeah I made like a three-minute
video with him and it took like two
hours to film because I just kept on
asking like really in-depth questions
about tea production and though like the
different types of tea and like none of
that ended up in the video
it's just in your head it's just I just
wanted to know it for me
and then you've got the short film the
tea chronicles yeah by the way you've
got super cool posters oh yeah the whole
set of your short films is like what
five four short films or short films
four but five posters no four I want to
believe there's five posters there's
four posters but they don't cool it's
like there's a fifth one yeah what's
confusing is that I so I got to make the
series of short films funded by YouTube
and they wanted me to make five of them
but I they also gave me a deadline and I
was having trouble reaching that so for
the last film it's kind of like it's
technically five films cuz it's like
it's the last film is - it takes place
in two parts so it's like the last film
is twice as long as all the other films
but I split it up into total so I could
say I have made five films but there are
only four posters but one of them is the
T Chronicles which I the description is
a
psychological horror comedy film about
tea yep
how long was that idea brewing really
just crack myself I want to know the
answer I want to acknowledge how ass it
was I guess it was like a month or so so
I was living with my friend cayenne and
he kind of came up with the idea he's a
youtuber as well yeah originally we
wanted to sort of just do it as a
YouTube sketch this is before YouTube
came to me and said you wanted some
money to make some short films so I
that's an interesting I think a lot of
people listening would be like what that
happens YouTube can give you money to
make stuff like how does that work
it was a program they were doing called
the creator Innovation Program where
they were coming to some youtubers and
being like we can give you a little bit
of money to do something cooler on your
YouTube channel something you always
wanted to do no we got it investments to
through the same program to do our
half-hour show the mythical show which
we didn't ten episodes of so yeah that
was like what the three years ago two
years ago now
something yeah okay so yeah that's where
the money came from yeah and then the
idea came from a well yeah Cayenne moved
in with me and he started making me a
lot of tea and I would always offered to
make him tea and he would always decline
it and then we kind of talked a bit
about that and felt like there was a an
idea for a horror movie in there
somewhere we wanted to kind of like
throw in a bunch of Alfred Hitchcock
references into it and it was like we
wanted to do it as a YouTube sketch then
YouTube said you wanna make some short
films and we were writing it and we
realized it could probably work as a
short film I guess it kind of feels like
an extended YouTube sketch in a way the
tea chronicles mm-hmm but yeah that's
where it came from it was it was kind
idea and we wrote it together and
directed it to give her as well I mean
it's I definitely want to get back to
the different things you've been able to
do like the creative bones you've been
able to stretch you don't stretch bones
you stretch muscles if you stretching
bones it's a problem I think as baby can
stretch bones I think in the UK they
stretch bones that's why I said okay
it's saying yeah right is that a saying
in the UK sure but let's let's go
through the whole journey yeah you've
got you've got quite a track
record just on YouTube like going back
basically all the way but let's go back
even further than that let's go back to
the womb Charlie the beginning of
Charlie yeah I don't remember what the
womb was like it was great yeah well it
was perfectly serviceable I came out
just fine
what's that first memory the womb was
perfectly serviceable that should be a
t-shirt and one of us has to make that
t-shirt you're us you go it could be a
tea blend which don't help ask us to
help with marketing I feel like I can't
really remember much of what happened to
me before I started YouTube though I
don't know if you have that kind of same
vibe where it feels like there's this
like this this kind of wall between like
my past YouTube self and my current one
like YouTube world where I can't well I
mean so your first YouTube videos I mean
you were what 17 I was 16 when I started
yeah where were you were you from I'm
from a place called Bath originally
which was a city founded by the Romans
at chrysalis as it was originally called
some natural Hot Springs they're a
really really pretty place in England
actually like I didn't realize how
pretty it was until I moved to London
and saw sort of like the grotty side of
the city and was like oh I actually had
a really really nice place to have to
grow up in so my mum still lives there
so I go back to see her quite often
there's actually a bath North Carroll is
which is the oldest Outer Banks town in
North Carolina I think or something
that's what I've heard I guess it was
named after your your hometown I
received so yeah is because my bath is
like yeah thousands and thousands of
years old yeah oh yeah we know we know
how this work you owned us yeah we're
but we're cool now yeah right yeah so
what is okay it's a small we're talking
like a like a this quaint village II
place that's what we like to picture you
know you can picture that future like
women coming out and like oh god no hood
and sweeping the the front steps is that
what it was like yeah it's like a
fantasy music playing um yeah and we'd
all sort of talking so like incredibly
posh accent the whole time as well I'm
sorry I am sorry that we're being this
way it's okay I'm used to it no I know
you're used to been the British YouTube
guy for a long time it's kind of so what
what did you do for fun what did I do
for fun well I did a lot of acting
actually like when I was really young my
my mum I was pretty shy kid I'm still a
shy guy generally now but my mum saw how
quite how shy I was and she was like I
want to put you into acting classes to
hopefully make you more confident so I
got into doing that was in a lot of
plays growing up when I was younger do
the acting work though did it did it
help the shyness I think it did to a
certain extent more than anything I feel
like YouTube was the thing that really
kind of boosted my confidence I think I
was always a pretty shy guy and I guess
that doing acting stuff kind of had
helped a bit and I also kind of needed
that like acting kind of like bass I
think to get into YouTube to feel
confident did enough to do that but it's
been a pretty slow process for me I
think but you don't recall it being
laced with anxiety to have to for your
mom to kind of push you in out of your
comfort zone no I never already felt
like doing acting was was like going out
of my comfort zone I don't know what it
is but I feel like I've always been
pretty comfortable kind of like doing
like plays and performances versus like
interacting with humans normally as my
whole self I don't know what it is but
it's like you there's a there's a
difference you can make work you can
when you're playing a character which
you know I was when I was doing plays
and we all do as well to a certain
extent when we're doing like video blogs
as well I think where we have like you
know the YouTube persona which is still
pretty close to how I actually am but
it's still go to a certain extent it's
still of performance you know so it it
feels like I don't know what it is about
that that makes it just like easier to
sort of like talk talk to people and
talk about things and when you get to
kind of like express yourself through a
script that you've written instead of
just sort of like mumbling swords to
someone one on one just makes it easier
I don't know what it is about that
though what you you're a very thoughtful
guy you
you can tell that there's a lot of just
analytical thinking that goes into the
way that you approach your career and
what we see you know on the internet so
I have this like image of little Charlie
it's like this very contemplative little
kid who is like kind of a serious kid
mm-hmm is that an incorrect assumption I
think I was pretty serious I think but I
also wanted to have fun like that's why
I started YouTube is I was very much
just like bored and I saw people doing
it like I saw video bloggers like
appearing on the front page of YouTube
that when people actually used to get
featured and I was like I could probably
do then I have just like the the really
like basic equipment like a stupid cheap
laptop and like a 15-pound webcam and I
thought yeah I could I could do that
which is obviously very different to how
it is now I never feel like most people
can watch like you know Sol don't be
like yeah I could do that I could spend
like a couple of thousand pounds on a on
a nice nice camera and start doing that
but back then it was a much like easier
to think I could get into this this this
would be fun but so but it was all just
for fun I mean even your acting were you
thinking I'm gonna I'm gonna be an actor
I'm gonna be an entertainment type thing
or was it I'm just I'm still young and
this is just so I'm just doing this
stuff because it's fun I think my more
kind of like analytical side probably
came as I got older you know because I
did start youtubing when I was like 16
so I was still you know I was still
pretty young I never really had like a
definite plan for what I wanted to do
with my life even when YouTube was my
job like it really was just like here is
a fun thing that I like to do and oh I
guess it's making me money now so that's
nice
oh oh I guess it's making me enough
money now that I could move out so I
guess it's my job but I never really
liked it took me quite a while to
actually pick what I wanted to do of
myself like I never consciously said I
want to be an entertainer I was just
sort of doing that and it was working
for me and that was nice it was only in
really in like the last few years that I
kind of like decided like I you know I
tried a lot of kind of like different
like forms of like entertainment like
doing music stuff and doing some
filmmaking and I guess doing like acting
and things like that and it was only
yeah like in the last couple of years
that I thought I kind of picked
filmmaking as my thing that just like
see
that seemed like the thing I was most
passionate about I guess having said
that I still do like doing all of the
other stuff as well but I guess now if I
was to kind of like pick a focus it
would be that but it's still like that's
still not my job like video blogging is
still that thing but back when you're 16
and you're just you're you're you're
watching youtubers mm-hmm like who were
the people you were watching that you're
like I'm gonna do that oh man okay so
Caitlyn Hill l88 do you remember Blount
III thousands yes that's cool no no
you're thinking about there is a puppet
who was the puppet sock guy I can't
remember right now I don't know why I
thought that Blount II was because there
was something that's all like that I
know what it was there was that sock guy
on YouTube did a response to Blount II
and that's what God made him big yeah
and I can't remember the video or
anything about it now but it was a sock
puppet responding to him so I never
watched Blount II I feel like I remember
that vaguely uh was then just a vlogger
you just a vlogger yeah like renetto you
talking about yeah I I didn't I wasn't
too into renetto but I did I did what
was aware of him but yeah there was a
book kind of the people for me how I was
like yeah that's like this that's so
that's first for YouTube I mean that's
ground-floor I think if we if we go boom
as well and you remember those oh yeah
yeah here's another one and if we dig
back to like your earliest videos the
first video that's still public on your
channel you're referring to how your
channel is going to change yeah so I
mean how many videos are now private ooh
probably like 20 or so I guess so I had
this really weird thing when I first
started YouTube cubing where I was I was
on the website for like a month or so
amassed like an audience of like a
hundred people one of my featured videos
was featured on the front page I went
from like a hundred to like four
thousand which at the time was like whoa
this is so cool
and the front page was like the UK front
page or was it it was just the UK front
page okay then that just been introduced
so I got features I
was like getting an audience quite
quickly and then you know youtubered
have been around for a couple of years
already so there are people who are like
right there at the beginning who had
spent two years trying to like amass an
audience and then suddenly I'd come in
within like a month and like gotten the
same amount of views as they had and so
people were pretty pissed they were like
they started like using YouTube of like
featuring people irresponsibly and there
was like a little kind of like mini
YouTube drama at the time surrounding me
and how I kind of like didn't deserve
what I was getting kind of hey did you
respond to that did you did you talk
about it publicly yeah my response was
that I was too scared of what the
internet was was like cuz I suddenly my
computer was talking to me and it was
not being nice and I was like this is
really scary
and I don't want to do this anymore so I
deleted all of the videos from my
channel and I was earlie didn't like
actually deleted them and I said I don't
want to I don't want to do this were you
thinking about this was this a totally
solo thing at the time you know
sixteen-year-old kid just figuring this
out you know a like did your parents
know that this was happening we were you
talking to any friends about it like
over you're just like making all these
decisions on your own because it's 16
that's just kind of a it's a big deal I
was I wasn't my mom was aware of when I
was doing like it's pretty much as soon
as I got featured was when I told her
that I was like making stuff on YouTube
and it seemed to be going well but
everyone yeah I was pretty much making
those decisions by myself and it seems
like I don't know the right decision for
a 16 year old to make if you're getting
hate online to be like yes probably
should go away from this now so you
donated them and then what and then it
was actually blunt II 3002 made a video
then like there's this kid and people
are being mean to him so we should
probably be nice and then there was like
this this Ferrari of all of these other
videos being like we support you charlie
and then I put my videos back up and
then I kept it making them and now I'm
here you put them back up you reposted
them yeah but in but since then you've
private did them again yeah some of the
really old stuff is open private AIDS
and then it just so happens that that
chart like that charlie changes video
that is like the most recent one of with
just the video that I was kind of like
yeah this is okay I guess this seems
good enough and I just left it up but
you but they're private
because you don't like them essentially
yeah they're just like really
embarrassing things that I would prefer
people not to say I think every every
youtuber we've been on the platform row
goes through okay we actually we found
we found we went back not too long ago
like maybe a year or two ago in found
videos where we had given out our email
address so people get a sense into
things so quo e to get rid of those yeah
like use like the things that you find
when you go back yeah so I totally
relate that's how we still get but the
backing up just a little bit seeing as
your sense of humor and your vibe is
very self-deprecating the fact that you
that your name was Charlie is so cool
like like how what was what was the idea
there like when you when you came up
with that I think I wanted to call
myself Charlie as cool and I don't know
why because I was 16 and I thought that
would be a good username but that was
taken and so I
all right thought I'd go for Charlie is
so cool because I thought I you know
people normally add like numbers at the
end of their username if they if it's
taken so I'll add words and stand to be
a bit different that Charlie is so cool
was also taken so I went for Charlie
asuka like what are Charlie is cool and
charlie is so cool up to these days I
don't know we should we checked in with
those guys I haven't spoken to them in a
long time and they're still posting I
don't know how quickly you introduced
the old guy with the voiceover which
will play a clip right here you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool who is that guy and
when did you start adding him into the
end of your videos um so that is Stephen
Fry who is a comedian writer anchor in
the UK relatively like big deal in the
UK he's known as like a national
treasure he's a good export too though
we know yeah ok kids yeah you know that
was him from I had no idea that was even
fry but now that you say of course that
Stephen Fry how did you how did you work
that how early was that um I can't
remember exactly what it was it was like
a you know two or three years into
youtubing for me I guess I did an
interview on this show called carpool
with a guy called Robert Llewellyn
where he was just like interviewing
people that he knew people he thought
were interesting and he did one with me
and then he did one with Stephen Fry
immediately afterwards and I guess
Stephen Fry had seen mine and he spent
the like first five minutes of his
interview just talking about me
and so I sent him a message barring like
that was really nice thank you for doing
that my mum wants to have you over for
tea is that okay
and he said um well you can come to the
recording of one of my TV shows if you
like and we can meet each other then so
I did that and then afterwards I sent
him an email being like you up third in
all of my videos for the rest of time
like within like half an hour he sent
over that little clip with like a few
variations for me to pick from those
awesome yeah so have you stayed in touch
uh yeah I see him every now and then it
still remembers who I am which is nice
as long as you don't forget me Yeah
right yeah but yeah no it's just a super
lovely guy and then you're you're
vlogging career just started to snowball
I think so like a million subscribers
happened within what the first year uh
I'm not entirely sure to be honest it's
all still a bit of a blur to me yeah but
it happened eventually and you know
there was a long period where my channel
was like the most popular one in the UK
which made me feel pretty good at the
time and yeah I mean I'd kind of like
you had that initial thing of like one
of my videos getting featured and then
from there I felt like this kind of like
weird obligation to the people who were
watching me like as soon as I had any
kind of like sizable audience I was like
I want to keep making videos for these
people I feel like they I owe it to them
and so I really just like tried to keep
up the momentum from there and like I
had a few videos and things that went
viral but for the most part it was just
like trying to keep up keep up uploading
stuff for a long time yeah where do you
think that comes from because you can
you can sense I think that's one of the
things that people really like about you
and your fans really like about you is
that there's a you really care there's
like a deep sense of care and almost you
just said an obligation to your fans
that kind of finds its way into your the
way you present yourself and the way
that you think about your content and
how you'll make a video about how well
I'm gonna change this or I'm gonna do
this where do you think that
from um I really don't know I it's
always just sort of been a part of me
and like pretty quickly as well after
getting featured I was like I also feel
like I really need to use this platform
to do good stuff as well like I don't
know what it was that made me just want
to be like I owed this to these people I
have to try and be a good role model now
I have to try and use this platform to
like raise money for charity it just
felt like I don't know yeah you had like
the right things high sense of
responsibility that is very obvious and
and everything you do and there was an
association with the vlog brothers in
nerdfighteria that I think you know that
was a vibe that they were certainly
developing in terms of like charity work
and things like that that I think was
there a parallel track I feel like they
might have been a big inspiration in
that okay like it's difficult for me to
pinpoint exactly what I've been but I
was definitely you know I was a vlog
previs fan before I knew either of them
I started in 2007 in like April and they
started I think at the beginning of 2007
with their initial like Blood Brothers
2.0 hmm so I am yeah I I feel like
they've always been kind of like very
good role models generally on YouTube so
I guess they could have been there as a
Frank soon or I don't know I like to
think I'm just a nice person and and
maybe that's where it comes from
has it ever you know has a sense of
obligation because it's such a this is
not an easy job it means a fun job we
all love doing what we do but it's not
easy you know it takes a lot of work and
there's a lot of second-guessing
yourself there's a lot of doubting
yourself and your abilities and Riaan
trying to reinvent yourself and that
kind of thing it has it ever gotten to a
point where you're like maybe I
shouldn't keep doing this you know maybe
I should try something else as your
sense of responsibility and obligation
to your fans ever get into a place where
it was overwhelming to a point where you
might want to stop I feel like I've
definitely felt that before yeah and
when I have I've always tried to think
how can I adapt to my YouTube channel to
do something different to be kind of
like challenging myself like whenever I
get to a point basically where I'm like
where I just feel like I'm doing the
same thing over and over again that's
when I start to think how can I change
now what what is like and I think part
of that comes from just like you know
because I did
when I was 16 right my content is always
just like it's I've been trying to let
it grow up with me so I'm trying to kind
of like adapt and change it as I as I go
on so yeah whenever I do feel like I
don't know overwhelmed or just like or
just bored you know or just feeling like
this isn't really interesting to me
anymore
I always come straight to well you know
leaving entirely seems pretty drastic
and probably unnecessary and if I think
about this a bit more there's probably
something else I could be doing here
to make this more fun for me again do
you have something that you do that's
like your pastime of choice that would
in a moment's where you feel that way
that you're like okay I'm gonna go and
do this because there have been times in
your career where you might have made
like a video a month you know there's
been some stretches like that right so
what what else are you doing in those
times playing video games usually my
go-to if I'm feeling sad is to play
through Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time
if I'm really really yeah yes yeah
that's a good one it's a it's just like
that's the look like the best nostalgia
here I can possibly give myself who's
playing through that game and I'm a bit
of a control freak as well I my guess is
that a lot of youtubers are like this
right where you want to be like in
complete control of the content that
you're making so I'll of us want to do
our own thing and not go into TV is we
can we can make yeah whatever we want to
make and so part of that is like I like
going back to a video game that I'm like
really familiar with the world so I can
feel like completely in control of it
but yeah that's what I tend to do if I'm
if I need a bit of a nope but you know
five years I'm thinking well this should
be another Channel Charlie gaming
channel and I would just can play Zelda
again and again like every week explain
it is that I'm not gonna lie I do have
the YouTube channel the legend of
Charlie it's ready to go
ready to go as and when I I plan
tentative plan for at some point in my
life was to you know try out the the
whole let's play thing is this breaking
news it can be if you want but I don't I
don't know what its gonna launch if ever
well it's there you're gonna get some
subs man just from that yeah maybe I
mean it is there does exist and I've
been considering doing it
for a long time and I would want to play
you know any video game that know my
plan know eighter like no sir I only
play that way just just every little
exotic all the way through now what did
you think about the adventure of link
did you ever play play that the
originally there was like the second
Nintendo version I so that's a bit
before my time I did go right to play it
and because it have that has that been
put out on any sort of like emulator or
anything I say like you can get it on
like the Nintendo Virtual Console like
on the Wii U or whatever because of the
ironic thing about this conversation is
that we have link here and he's never
played any of these and there's a
there's a game called The Adventure of
Link which was the one that I kind of
like that was the first one that I liked
with a friend like got into his like
even at the time when link was my best
friend he who still wouldn't play the
games when he tried to go to Ben's house
to play The Adventure of Link I'm a
friend named Lincoln I'm going to play
the adventurous in it I when you're
living the adventure why play it oh but
that one and if I would have said that
at the time I would have probably been
cooler then I was yeah is that Jesus is
that your Denise don't you hit then so
that when you go back to well I don't
because I did week I guess it would be
on the emulator somewhere but I haven't
gone back right but because they're even
even though just even like the original
Legend of Zelda it still would take too
much time for me at this at this point
you know like and my son actually got
ocarina of time and started trying to
play through that and he got a little
too easy he still has it but he's gotten
a little discouraged bogged down got a
little bogged down yeah I think they're
getting right there is a little bog that
was sure in Boggs probably a bogan so
it's more about you know sort of
vicariously watching him right we want
to break in here right quick just to
mention our sponsor who helped make this
ear biscuit possible Squarespace
building a website could be tough and
even if you do know your way around code
and creating something that looks good
and works well is a time consuming
affair whether it's for a business site
a portfolio a restaurant whatever else
you need a website even if it's just for
yourself and your amazing exploits in
life like that time you did that tandem
skydiving and you want to make a website
about metics
parents don't do that but you pot you
doing most people need a website you
need one and lucky for you and all of us
Squarespace makes it easy to build
beautiful websites without breaking a
sweat
Squarespace provides simple powerful and
beautiful websites that look
professionally designed regardless of
skill level no coding required not only
the Squarespace provide you with an
intuitive and easy-to-use set of tools
to create your website with Squarespace
also has state-of-the-art technology
powering your site to ensure security
and stability for all of these reasons
we are currently redesigning our site
rhettandlink.com/store for you did you
can't beat the ease and simplicity of
Squarespace Squarespace gives you 24/7
online support and a beautiful website
for only $8 a month you can even get a
free domain if you by Squarespace for
the year so what are you waiting for
start a free trial with Squarespace no
credit card required and start building
your website today when you decide to
sign up for Squarespace make sure you
use our offer code okay that's rhett and
Link to get 10% off your first purchase
and to show your support for your
biscuits we think Squarespace for their
support of ears big ears biscuits yeah
your biscuits Squarespace build it
beautiful well since we've talked about
video games we should probably also talk
about religion okay like depends where
you want to go on wiki it says that you
identify as an atheist and have you
blogged about this or is this like just
something separate I mean it's really
like not a very important part of my
life to be honest is like I feel like
when I started thinking about like
religion in that way and I was like yeah
I guess I am an atheist then it kind of
did become a big part of my personality
for a bit and I feel like I probably
talked about it I've talked about it in
like like second channel videos a bit
and really nowadays it's like something
that doesn't really factor into cut so
you my personality I told you I get it
but you so you I I guess my interest is
in that in in the u.s. atheism is still
pretty stigmatize
but yeah I don't want to demonize but
because you have to like if you're an
atheist in the u.s. it's like you kind
of have to you can't just be like oh
this I'm an atheist and this isn't a big
thing to me because then you cut because
you immediately have to defend it right
yeah and it is it's like a bigger deal
yeah it seems like in the UK it's kind
of like okay yeah it's though that's
what you think about that that's cool I
think the best way to sum up is like in
the US on a $10 bill there are the words
In God We Trust written on it and in the
UK we have a picture of Charles Darwin
it's like it's really like not like big
of a deal right and if we had Darwin on
any you know currency and you well that
would be there wouldn't it would never
happen you know it wouldn't have anytime
soon but he is on the South Carolina
flag in so confused right now that's
what I that's what I was interested in
exploring was not what like calling you
on the carpet like what makes of what
why don't you believe in God
yeah but more of that cultural idea of
you just finding yourself well yeah
realizing that you're an atheist because
it's just something that is just you're
not called on the carpet for it that's
the culture I think so let's know
everybody anyway is an atheist but I
think that a lot of people in the UK
wouldn't kind of like they might
identify as being religious but it's not
even that isn't necessarily like a big
part of their lives like they might not
go to church they might just kind of
like be almost just like spiritual
people who just think yeah there
probably is a God and that's kind of
sometimes as far as they go obviously
there is you know religion in the UK and
it is a big thing for a lot of people
but um I guess for me growing up it
never really felt like that and so yeah
as soon as I realized yeah probably
don't believe in God then it was like
okay that's that's the thing about me
that I know now what's what's next yeah
how old were you did when you started
thinking about those things I must have
been must have been around the time that
I was like starting around YouTube I
think I think I was kind of like
agnostic for like the first couple of
years that I was like making videos and
then yeah that's pretty soon after that
Stephen Fry is it pretty well spoken
he kind of talks about these issues
quite a bit he influenced you and
thinking about those things is that
where you were fan of his at the time um
I think I was a fan of his although I
don't know if it was him specifically
like like you said I feel like it's
because there are a lot of kind of like
prominent atheists I guess in the UK
people that I admired and you know found
out that that was something about them
so that probably kind of got me thinking
about it although I did you know I spent
a lot of my teenage years kind of like
not wanting to go either way with it
really just kind of wanting to it's kind
of my default position in life whenever
I can is just to kind of sit on the
fence unless I yeah kind of like feel
confident enough to say something kind
of new about myself but you but there's
no there's no impulse to say to make
this a part of your sort of public
identity in a way that like I'm going to
you know because there are plenty of
youtubers who are like okay that's the
atheist youtuber yeah there their
mission is kind of to break down
religious constructs kind of expose them
and that kind of thing there's no
impulse to get involved with that I tell
you what it's more important to me is I
like you know I'm a big fan of critical
thinking and was a big fan of like
science so I talk about those things on
my youtube channel and I have a kind of
like a series dedicated to talking about
science but it doesn't really feel like
a worthwhile thing to me to be like I
want to talk about atheism it just feels
like I don't know it feels like a
certain like conflict that is not really
fun to get into all the other time I
like to talk about the things that I
kind of believe in that I think like
important to me which a lot of that is
like critical thinking in science that's
kind of like if there's any kind of like
spiritual part of me it comes from like
hearing about amazing things from the
universe so that's kind of the thing I
want to like enro heart to people if
there's anything you know I want to look
at the positive side of like the things
that I do believe in and what's that
series called I can't I I know that I
watched a few of these fun science fun
science yeah which you've you've tackled
different topics including what um what
have I done I did the first one was on
the moon I did one on lights one on
sound I've done one oh yeah I've been
like wanting to kind of come back to it
for a long time as well although I I
kind of feel like it's one of those
ideas where if I did come back to it I'd
wanted
as like a more produced kind of thing I
kind of would want to do it like like a
kind of show on my youtube channel as
opposed to how it was before where it
was just like I do a video blog and it's
called fun science and I'll talk about
science science he things now I'd like
to see if I if I could do it again how I
could turn it into like a bigger thing
is a stargazing and breast gazing one of
those that was just that was me off in a
Gran Canaria well we went stargazing on
the holiday at some point and also a lot
of women had their breasts out and so
let's talk about that sure so this is a
topless beach no it was just a beach
just just with just many beaches that I
would go to there and it'll be like oh
you just got your top off I guess
welcome to Europe and then where is the
beach uh it was on an island called Gran
Canaria in the Canary Islands okay and
what's your interaction with those what
with breasts oobs what do you mean your
girlfriend I was there with my
girlfriend yeah what's her name Emily
Emily um and Emily's a filmmaker yeah
she is you uh you talk on your channel
about her her film cold mm-hmm which
certainly looked that way yeah and so
you were there what was your role in
shooting a short film and then I'll come
back to how you interact with her with
all the boobs on the beach yeah welcome
back to the important stuff yeah yeah so
that was Emily's hadn't had that film
funded by a new film digital and funding
lots of people to make short films
recently to hopefully get turned into
into series did she direct wrote and
directed it she wrote and directed that
movie and what did you do
I edited it but she so she was producing
your early short films yeah so she
produced offline for me as well that's
actually how we met before we were kind
of like yeah a couple is she she made a
film for me which was very nice of her I
want you to keep doing this but instead
of paying you I'm just gonna be a
boyfriend yeah she is she did my
subsequent films after that strangers in
the beds and our brother she produced
both of those and so when the new form
digital thing
came around it was very much just like
it's it's your turn to make a movie this
time and also I don't know how to
produce a film that's not something I'm
good at so I wanted to be involved in a
key role if I can and so she asked me to
edit it as I've edited like a lot of my
own short films as you know so it's
something I had experience doing and
that was that was really fun and
actually like I've never yeah I like it
was the first time I had that experience
it's like making a film that wasn't mine
right like not I you know comes back to
this kind of like being a control freak
kind of thing where I felt like I needed
to be writing and directing my own
movies in order to feel like I was like
being creatively fulfilled but so long
as I'm working on something that I think
is great right you don't nail it like
and I you know obviously editing is like
a big role then you get to make a lot of
cool creative cute choices but I was
ultimately not the person in control
completely but I trusted Emily and I
thought the film is gonna be good so I
still got a lot out of the experience of
doing that what was that process like I
mean in being in a relationship but
working on a project together I mean a
that can be stressful mm-hmm depending
on the dynamic in the relationship but
then taking someone's vision and editing
it I mean surely this led to some
arguments of some you're not a very
argumentative guy so you might be about
to say we didn't argue at all but what
really has I'll try and think and see if
there are any instances where we did
argue but I honestly it just solved
didn't happen I feel like I don't know
what it is about mine and Emily's
relationship but we are just very very
good at just like flipping the switch
and being like okay we're in work mode
now and now we're in relationship mode
and she didn't get mad at you when you
were staring at the boobs
we were both staring you know yeah right
they were there is some time in the
world and we thought well there they are
it's hard to take your eyes off
sometimes when then when they're there
um lots of different sizes and shapes
and you know I think in that video
talked about a bit about like you know
confidence and how I wished and I was
comfortable enough to you know share my
breasts with the world what were we
talking about the relationship so okay
so if you're if you don't find yourself
there's not a lot of conflict and
working together how do you guys handle
conflict in your relationship because
you are you're you're very
a particular an opinionated guy no but
you're also just you're you're good
agreeable guy you don't huh you know you
don't seem like you get mad very often I
really don't get mad very often like I
and I don't think Emily or I really
enjoy conflict very much so you know
obviously like level relationships we
have points where we'd you know how
things we disagree on and but we get
through it just just fine by not
shouting at each other that's not
something we're interested in doing at
all most of the time that I don't think
that have you ever shouted like I can't
picture it
I can I can shout I have done in the
past I've been I've been known to I
think on occasion but yeah it doesn't
happen super often I would be very
scared of you if we were shouting you
know when you know where somebody who's
who's like this very collected you know
it seems just very even keel mm-hmm that
person getting upset is like I don't
wanna be around the situation that got
away I got them upset about something
I've definitely screwed up you know
there's no doubt right yeah I think
that's the power you have charlie yeah
it is it's like somebody raveh tossed
it's like the person who you know
doesn't speak a whole lot but when they
do say something you listen mm-hmm you
know usually I'm definitely that person
would you have that like emotionally you
have that it's a superpower yeah III
know that if I ever got to a point where
I was like shouting it suddenly about
something because I was so angry that's
that's what I know that something is
seriously wrong the real and I should be
very worried one of the things that one
of the things I kind of see in your
vlogs like when you're being charlie is
like we talked about your self
deprecating tone but there's maybe a
more specific way to describe it is you
almost have an apologetic tone it's just
you know there's this like okay guys I
got to tell you this thing and I'm gonna
do it and I'm gonna do it in a very
entertaining and endearing way that's
gonna make you want to watch more of my
videos but I kind of seem like I'd
rather not be doing this at the moment
that is it a kind of a specific way I
could describe it hopefully that doesn't
come across as an insult it's it's it's
a you know totally
it's a it's this apologetic self
deprecating tone but does that is that
is that true that there is this like
okay I'm kind of doing this because I
know you want me to and does that lead
to your interest in doing the short film
which is a more you know you're able to
kind of create like you said it's a
script and it's it's a different kind of
art form and you're able to present
yourself and your ideas in a different
way is you you gravitate towards short
film because of that I think that when
it comes to like doing the short films
it's very much like you know I'm a
multi-faceted yeah human being right I'm
complicated I have lots of thoughts and
feelings when it came to the the video
blogging there's a there's a specific
side of me that I can show you through
that like I very much want my video
blogs to be pretty light-hearted and
pretty you know fun and to be you know
something that will will brighten
someones day you know that I really want
that to be the case and there are there
are you know facets of my personality
and things I think about that don't feel
appropriate to talk about in kind of
like a more kind of like serious manner
like my last you know short film I made
was about death and I wanted to talk
about death in a very kind of like
serious way and about mourning and the
importance of mourning correctly and it
didn't really feel like I could just sit
and talk about that in a video blog it
doesn't it doesn't feel right like I've
actually made a video about death before
on my youtube channel but it was still
that kind of like kind of jovial like
here's a light-hearted look at it and
when I want to do something more serious
sometimes it feels more right to do it
in kind of like a short form like a in a
short film like format well you know I
will say we haven't we haven't talked
about this specifically but when you
screened our brother or as wonderful a
the second part one a head buffer fest
we of course first of all we're
backstage and we can't really see I
could we could kind of get an idea of
what it was about and it seemed very
serious but you can't really hear it cuz
you're behind the speakers and
everything and just to get background we
are we're backstage because we are
tasked to introduce the next act after
your film screens and it was it was it
was like something very light
hard-hearted but you're right your phone
I mean how would you describe the short
film it's a pretty sad film right I mean
it's like the the thing I want people to
gather I wanted to cry at it like if
they do that and I'm like great if the
film did its job yeah I wasn't a couple
yeah everyone in the audience is crying
yeah and also thinking about like
mourning and the ways to do it properly
and what healthy mourning is and what
unhealthy mourning is all of that sort
of thing you know letting your feelings
out right it's it's a serious film if
you know it is and that's not to say
that I want all of my films in the
future to be like that at all I just
sort of wanted to try and see what it
would be like if I tried to do just a
straight-up drama about a topic I
thought was gonna be important to me so
you is the question it readies your
question gonna be was Charlie what was
Charlie's response to what we did when
we came out well I looked so for those
of you who weren't weren't at buffer
fest so Lincoln I had to get up there
after Charlie's film and then first of
all we are almost always just trying to
be funny so that's what people expect of
us and then we've got to introduce
something that's kind of light-hearted
so backstage we came up with the idea
and and then we go on say Shandling says
first of all I mean the films over and
people I mean it's it works what you
tried to accomplish it worked oh yeah
you've got everybody in this very
emotional serious place and a tough spot
man and then says wow Charlie that was
hilarious
and then the tension just broke in the
room it was the biggest laugh of the
night that's the biggest laugh I've ever
got I was concerned I was like I don't
want it to seem heartless or like I did
we never we haven't talked about it
since then no no we did I'm pretty sure
we did we did I'm pretty sure I see I
saw a fly upwards buffer fish yes we did
I could tell that you were like worried
about where you go because you know for
like absolutely everyone else in that
room it's like exactly the thing you
need to do but for me specifically you
could feel like is he gonna it's okay
that we did this and I laughed so it's
fine it really it really was
yeah okay well let's you know with with
all the different creative endeavors and
things you've done over the journey
let's talk about cereal time okay which
is a huge project that you know you've
just launched and
I'm interested you know in in doing a
similar format I know that it's a level
of putting yourself out there then when
you describe yourself as I mean you said
you were a control freak and you're
you're a calculating artist and
everything you do that's been cleared
through a whole conversation I'm curious
you know what's your interaction with
putting yourself out there in in in that
daily talk show format right that's
scary um yeah no it was scary obviously
if people don't know about stereotype
you might be quite familiar with the
format because we've obviously we taken
direct inspiration from you guys with
good mythical morning and yeah I mean a
big reason that we wanted to that I
wanted to do it is I wanted to find a
way where I could essentially be making
a show that kind of played a bit more by
the play but by the YouTube playbook
that would be because you know I that
there's a big demand on YouTube to be
uploading regularly and to be kind of
like making content that's like keeping
people on the website and all of that
stuff just didn't really fit with my own
YouTube channel and so I wanted to find
a where I could do that sort of thing
where I would also be kind of like
creatively fulfilled like a lot of
youtubers do that through doing daily
vlogs Ryan it's that same sort of thing
where it's like long videos where you're
really getting an insight into kind of
like the kind of person that they are
and I bets the first thing I tried right
as I try to do something I did like a
weekly vlog one weekly vlog and really
didn't enjoy the like the process of
doing and I don't know if you've ever
tried that before but it's like I found
that it really just disconnected me from
my own life it just really made the like
I I wasn't I wasn't living presently in
the moment at all I didn't really
remember the week that I had through
because I was trying to figure out the
best way to film it the whole time so
the the lovely thing about the format
for me is it's like it allows me to kind
of be like I feel like on cereal time a
bit more of myself like then I am kind
of like on my main youtube channel or at
least it's a different facet of myself
that people don't normally get to see
because it is all happening in pretty
much in one take if I leave it if I
stumble then we tend to leave that stuff
in and so it kind of like it shows
people like that slightly I think maybe
more an authentic version of how I am
like if
you were to kind of like actually chat
with me in person it feels more like
like that but that's the risk right it
is that you had to calculate that you
were willing to take yeah and I think
that this is the the tricky thing to get
over I think and it's an important thing
to kind of like bear in mind I think for
like all video bloggers is like people
are really looking for like authenticity
right and we can we can say that like
with video blogging it's like it's it is
it is very authentic a lot of the time
you know you are seeing real people
talking but also when it comes to video
blogging you know you want to kind of
like heavily edit it you want to kind of
like script it you want to make it feel
like you know a piece that you're
sharing with people and sometimes that
means that you're not kind of like
completely sharing the kind of person
you actually are all the time because
that is a really scary thing to do but
it's also I think what people really
like to see they want they want to see
like you know I think kind of like some
of the most like interesting insights
into people come from like
fly-on-the-wall documentaries where the
person in the the subject of the film is
does not have any control over how that
film is going to come across right those
are just like such interesting character
pieces so it was important to me to find
a way where I could like try and be more
of myself and have a bit less control
over like that sort of thing to show
people like a more authentic version of
who I actually Adam it might be scary
for me but I think people I hope that
people would be more interested in
saying that and what's been the reaction
from fans I'm seeing that that side of
you presented it that way um I think
they like it for sure and yeah having a
lot of fun doing in I haven't really
experienced quite as much like
engagement before as I did with cereal
time you know and that's a thing we
tried focus a lot when we're making the
show as well as to figure out ways that
we can kind of include people in the
show as much as possible and as a result
a lot of people kind of like do seem to
what like I feel like I get more fan out
for cereal time than I do for myself
right people just seem like really
interested in in getting involved so
that's just a side of it that like you
know I tend to try and measure like
success generally on YouTube not by like
views but by like engagement and not by
just like how many likes or comments but
like the kind of engagement that is hard
to measure like people
during fan of people kind of like
creating stuff based on things that
you've made or like wanting to go to
your shows like those kind of like more
abstract kind of things that if I if I
see that then I'm like okay this means
that people are really kind of like
interested in the thing and that bro
feel better than you know I prefer to
have like a thousand people who just
like really really care about what I'm
doing then like a million people just
kind of like passively watch a video
right well there is a reward for putting
yourself out there you know so we wish
you the best in that we appreciate you
putting yourself out there here man yeah
our friendship goes way back so it's
cool to finally sit down and get the
full story hanging out thank you for
having me it's been lovely yeah
perfectly serviceable better and there
you have it
our ear biscuit with Charlie McDonald
charlie is so cool like true statement
yes he is so cool like what like this
little like things that are like cool
tweet at Charlie let him know what you
think about our conversation hashtag ear
biscuits his Twitter handle is cool like
C double O L is there another L than an
i ke I think there's a double L right in
there yeah that's too else see mm cool
and like yeah it's not cool like it's
cool and like he actually got that C
double o Double L single eye single K
singly you don't like we said when we
were talking to Charlie I think we
mentioned this a couple of times he has
this thoughtfulness to the way he
approaches things and this
self-deprecating humor and approach to
things that I think is as he
demonstrated even in our conversation
today it's one of the things that makes
him a likeable guy he's easy to like
because he's good at what he does he's
entertaining at the stuff that he can
create something to entertain you it
actually entertained you but you get as
to what well I mean you're talking about
general
YouTube stuff no I'm just saying that
you know he's good at what he does no
period but that doesn't being good at
what you do doesn't make you likeable if
you're good at what you do but you have
he has this he kind of second guess him
guesses himself like he doesn't think a
whole lot of himself and that is an
attractive quality I think that's why
he's built one of the reasons he built a
fan base that wants to connect with him
personally because he's just doesn't
seem like a guy who's full of himself
I'm not saying that like most youtubers
are full of themselves just every once
in a while you talk to somebody who just
seems like this person really is humble
he wouldn't describe himself in that way
because if you're really humble you
shouldn't call yourself humble you can't
be prideful about being humble that's
like he's when heat is truly as they
would say in the Old South and humble
without the aged guy have you ever heard
anyone actually say humble my
grandmother-in-law really says humble
yep really she's from the Old South man
she still calls it the War of Northern
Aggression oh gosh I mean this is Old
South hmm well let's we should have
asked Charlie about that sure he'd have
lots of good thoughts yeah I mean he he
really he holds himself in such a way
that I know that anything he says he
he's thought through it you know he kind
of has that gravitas about him which is
interesting for a comedic voice maybe
maybe I could learn something from that
link hey but don't you think it's an
interesting combination of like I mean
self-deprecating is a form of humor but
this but there's something else that's
like this this thoughtful gravitas that
I will call it which is not it's not
common in musical comedy metered self
metered okay so is that a word did I
make that up Charlie let us know he's a
gas meter if you've ever been described
as metered I don't even know what it
means but I'm gonna try measured charlie
is so metered like charlie is so
measured that's going to be his like his
iPhone channel which day people remember
people use we should observe that for
him
all right guys we're actually opening a
new shop where we start to speculatively
Reserve YouTube channels for iPhone vlog
accounts for people who are so late to
the game they're never gonna do that
okay we never do what we tried that for
a little bit that's what our second
channel started off as I'm digressing
yeah and you guys regress right back the
music is playing me out of my own ear
biscuit now trade I'm gonna Kevin cut an
egress right through to the end of this
thing
how many Gress words can we come up with
as you guys are exiting through the
outro we will hasn't be have aggressing
it oh you digress you regress you're the
prime gonna make some progress you threw
my egress to the end but I digress
and all you egrets should leave a review
on iTunes and that selfie for us also
comment on come out clouds its
SoundCloud I said cloud cloud and I
don't know I'm gonna resist join us next
month that clown cloud desperate times
call for a video plays let's just end
this yeah
[Music]
[Music]